you know it's interesting there's been
this phenomenon on the Internet of
people tweeting out pictures of their
pets and asking you specifically saying
hey Ellen Page
can you name my pet for me how the hell
did that get started it started when
someone sent me a picture of their dog
and was like name my dog and I did and
then I got a lot of photos of dogs cats
plants a variety of that case yeah okay
when people ask you to name plants and
we actually this is a real example
someone tweeted Ellen Page will you name
my for cat died did you remember these
did you did you name these guys yes
it's Albert Dana sauce and bucket also
you name this person's cactus right here
guys so one on the Rights Tippi I think
one was Eric sassy and Luke okay yeah my
question is how much time do you invest
do you just look at him and go bill
Steve Moe and Curly or is it it was
quick its immediate I like to think I'm
you know I'm a vessel you know for them
so you're saying God speaks to you of
all the people on the planet God is
talking to you and it's to named cacti I
don't make the rules code yeah I know
yes as I know this is your gift and Who
am I to say yeah hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please